movies have an immense power to connect
people i mean when you turn a movie on
whether it is in your living room with
your family
or you know if you make plans with the
friends to go out and
you get your popcorn together and you
kind of come together the fact that we
come out of watching movies talking
about something
feeling provoked making memories
that's what connection is and i think
cinema
connects they're they're so popular
movies have such a large part of pop
culture
because of the fact that they have an
amazing ability
to connect the world i mean what have
most people been doing
during quarantine you know everyone has
been sitting and watching movies and tv
shows
and just imagine life not having that
at a time like this when all of us were
home i remember when i first went back
to work in october
i really felt that i felt that you know
movies have given people
sanity during this really unprecedented
time
and it gave me a sense of pride
to you know um be a part of
um of something that is so large that
helps people come together and keep
their families feeling a sense of
normalcy i guess and you know that's
it's really cool to see the power of
that
hi guys i'm priyanka and for more videos
like this subscribe to the oscars
channel